Hello, everyone!
If you’re a fan of SCP Explained, you’ll
know that we regularly post interesting questions
in our community tab, asking for responses
from you - our dear fans.
These have ranged from questions about specific
anomalies, like SCP-096, or your suggestions
on how we should actually kill SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile.
We’ve even asked you which anomalous powers
you’d want to have, and posed your questions
directly to SCP-343, also known as God, and
of course, the terrifying and infamous Scarlet
King.
But in our latest community question, asking
you about hypothetical crossovers between
the SCP Foundation and the weird, wild multiverse
of all fiction, you truly outdid yourself,
with thousands upon thousands of responses.
And we thought, rather than just making one
video selecting our favorites, we’d turn
each of our favorites into whole videos.
And how are we going to do that?
That’s when this wonderful state-of-the-art
gizmo comes into play!
You may remember the Anom-O-Tron 6000, our
incredibly advanced artificial intelligence-driven
supercomputer designed specifically to run
simulations for the SCP Foundation.
We’ve fed this computer data from countless
SCP Foundation experiments and cross tests,
and all the data from your suggestions.
This will allow the fine folks at the SCP
Foundation to explore any anomalous hypothetical,
without risking the lives of staff members
or civilians.
This brings us to our first simulation, suggested
in a huge number of comments: Could SCP-682
be Contained Within the Backrooms?
For those not in the know, the Backrooms is
an internet urban legend that’s spiraled
into a full-blown phenomenon.
It’s built on the premise that if you’re
not careful and enter certain specific circumstances,
you can no clip out of our reality, and enter
a terrifying, multi-level alternate reality,
where you’re stalked by a variety of bizarre
and frightening creatures.
This could be a complete nightmare for your
average person, but how would it play out
if SCP-682, the endlessly angry Hard to Destroy
Reptile, found its way inside?
Also, for another Backrooms-related surprise,
stick around until the end of the video…
In the meantime, though, let’s boot up the
Anom-O-Tron and test this new scenario!
The worst had happened: Again.
SCP-682 had busted out of containment during
a cross test and started making a beeline
for the nearest populated area.
Several helicopters containing heavily-armed
MTF Nu-7, “Hammer Down”, members were
in hot pursuit, attempting to slow the vicious
reptile down with targeted sniper fire at
its legs.
But it seemed that these efforts were all
for naught: SCP-682 had already reached the
defunct industrial district on the edge of
a nearby city, and if the beast managed to
actually reach a populated area, all hell
would break loose.
That’s when they pulled out the heavy weaponry:
Miniguns mounted to the helicopters unleashed
a rain of hellfire down onto SCP-682.
However, 682 managed to dodge most of the
bullets and simply tank the rest.
Command authorized the use of heavy ordinance:
The helicopter’s missile launches.
They’d pick up the pieces afterwards, once
SCP-682 was back in containment.
However, the reptile had plans of its own.
It charged into a nearby abandoned chemical
plant to avoid the gunfire from above.
This was exactly what Hammer Down wanted.
The helicopters circled around the chemical
plant and unleashed a barrage of powerful
incendiary missiles, blowing the plant to
kingdom come in hopes of dragging an incapacitated
682 out of the rubble afterwards.
But when the smoke had cleared and only the
rubble was left, 682 was nowhere to be seen.
Even for the hardcore operatives of Hammer
Down, this caused an anxiety spike.
Had it tunneled into the ground?
Had it adapted to the attack by turning invisible
or getting tiny to escape?
It’d done all these things before.
Or after all the deranged attempts at putting
SCP-682 in the ground, had some light firebombing
killed the monster?
Whatever the case, they’d need to search,
in case SCP-682 popped up somewhere else and
started causing havoc.
If it was still alive - which it probably
was - they couldn’t rest on their laurels
until they’d found it again.
Meanwhile, SCP-682 woke up.
It felt groggy and irritated, its body resting
against an unpleasant, soggy carpet.
It licked the carpet - the moisture had the
distinct flavor of human spinal fluid, which
682 had tasted many times before.
The sickly yellow walls and incessant buzzing
from the fluorescent lights up above were
nauseating, and it gave 682 a nagging headache.
This only made 682’s default emotion - blistering
rage and hatred - even worse.
It began walking around, exploring this strange,
spatially anomalous environment.
Was this more of that frustrating Foundation
trickery?
Another one of those puerile “cross-tests”?
The last thing 682 remembered was running
at one of the walls in the chemical plant
- a wall that, in hindsight, seemed darker
than the others - but rather than shattering
through the brickwork, it was here now, in
this strange, tacky lobby that never seemed
to end.
It was like a kaleidoscope of empty, 1990s
office kitsch.
Endless worthless yellow walls arranged like
some labyrinthine, nonsensical maze, leading
nowhere and devoid of all life as SCP-682
wandered through it.
And of course, SCP-682 found it disgusting.
It was only on Level 0, and already, 682 hated
the Backrooms just as much as it hated our
dimension.
Someone or something had to pay for the crime
of inconveniencing it this way, and it would
happily turn this whole dimension inside out
just to find some beings to kill inside it.
Yes, that would be great fun…
SCP-682 began its frantic search for an exit,
evolving an innate sonar ability and picking
up speeds that would be impossible for human
beings.
This is the part where most people would go
mad, or die from hunger or thirst.
SCP-682?
Not so much.
It could keep searching, and searching, and
searching until the stars burned out in the
sky.
It would find its prey, somehow, and when
it did, it would put them through hell.
And as it turned out, this new universe rewarded
682’s dogged stubbornness, because when
it passed through a seemingly random hallway
after hours of searching, it was in a different
place entirely.
This place looked like some huge abandoned
warehouse complex with water shining off the
ground.
If 682 had more advanced knowledge of the
Backrooms, it would have known this was Level
1.
But the only number SCP-682 cared about was
body count, and in that regard, it would find
Level 1 to be a vast improvement.
Two groups of humans had established bases
in this level of the Backrooms: The Major
Explorer Group, a faction of professional
Backrooms traversers who maintained their
Base Alpha on this level, and the Backrooms
Nonaligned Trade Group, a commercial group
whose primary base is an economic hub on this
very level - A fortified city-like area with
a population of 412, which would, a few hours
after 682’s appearance, be a population
of zero.
But before all that, it felt like grabbing
a bite at the diner…
Tom’s Diner is a refuge for many people
trapped in the backrooms - a casual eatery
nestled into the cold warehouse environment
of Level 1, where people could get a warm
meal from Tom, a former cook who’s been
trapped in the Backroom for years.
SCP-682 was eager to be a part of this grand
tradition - But the Hard to Destroy Reptile
decided to buck the trend a little by just
devouring Tom himself.
From there, it decided to launch its rage-fueled
offensive against the various humanoid inhabitants
of the level.
Both the Major Explorers Group Base Alpha
and the Backrooms Nonaligned Trade Group Trade
Keep were heavily fortified against the kind
of entities these folks had gotten used to
facing in The Backrooms, but they were completely
unprepared for a creature of SCP-682’s sheer
power, intelligence, endurance, and ferocity.
The SCP Foundation had been studying the creature
for decades, with far more resources than
either of these two Backrooms-bound groups,
and they still had a hard time keeping the
beast consistently contained.
Sadly for the greatest bastions of human hope
in the Backrooms, SCP-682 swept through both
outposts in a matter of hours, killing everyone
there without an ounce of remorse.
The only person there it took its time with
was the final human being left in the decimated
remains of the Major Explorers Group Base
Alpha.
It grabbed the man by the throat and squeezed,
asking with its guttural, growing voice:
“You.
Were you and your dead brethren allied with
the SCP Foundation?”
Despite his fear, the Explorer told 682 that
he had never heard of the SCP Foundation.
Nor did he know what kind of entity 682 was.
“Hmm.
Then what is this place?
Tell me, and I might give you a quick death.”
The Explorer gave as good a response as he
could: 682 was trapped in the Backrooms, a
multi-level interdimensional nightmare filled
with dangerous creatures.
That made 682 curious - Dangerous creatures?
That could make an interesting challenge.
682 asked the Explorer how it could access
these other levels, and find these creatures,
and the Explorer explained that through exploring
these levels enough, anyone could “no clip”
into the next one.
It really was that simple.
With that, 682 knew all it needed to know
and carelessly murdered the final human being
of Level 1.
It had killed so many humans over its long
and twisted life - It was no different from
breathing air now, an utterly perfunctory
action.
It was eager to discover these other creatures
on the lower levels, and teach them a new
level of fear they’d never experienced…
682 stormed through the halls until it achieved
the next successful no clip into Level 2,
which manifested as a series of old, dilapidated
maintenance tunnels that seemed to stretch
on for millions of miles.
Wonderful.
There were humans here, too, apparently, but
who cared about them?
This was the first level to feature a smorgasbord
of “Entities”, ripe for the killing.
It sped through the tunnels, teeth, and fangs
borne, eager to deal death with gleeful abandon.
The first entities it encountered in the expansive
tunnels of Level 2 were a collection of beings
known as Crawlers: Insect-like creatures infected
with an extremely aggressive fungal growth.
Just getting close to them could present an
active risk to humans - Not so much for a
creature that could easily regenerate after
being tossed into the sun.
As the creatures tried to lunge, SCP-682 simply
crushed and devoured them with little effort.
They tasted a little stale, on account of
the fungus, but the chewiness was pleasing.
Hopefully, there would be more challenging
foes down in the tunnel than these mere insects,
SCP-682 thought to itself while journeying
deeper into the endless network of tunnels.
Soon enough, SCP-682 ventured into a section
of the tunnel engulfed in total darkness.
Its eyes quickly adjusted, developing immaculate
night vision.
That’s when it spotted another creature
sharing this little slice of darkness with
it: A pair of floating, glowing eyes and almost
cartoonish teeth, grinning like some maniacal
Looney Tune.
This is an entity known as a Smiler, and they’re
a terrifying threat to any humans venturing
through the Backrooms.
SCP-682…
Wasn’t impressed.
It began a perfect adaptation for the situation:
Its body began to glow, emitting incredible
levels of both heat and light, carving through
the darkness of the tunnel and causing the
Smiler to emit a terrible, piercing shriek.
The sheer heat of this new ability melted
sections of the Level 2 tunnels around SCP-682.
When the light finally dimmed down to slightly
more reasonable levels, where the Smiler once
stood was instead a fizzling black scorch
mark.
Another creature had painfully bitten the
dust, and SCP-682 was starting to have some
fun.
It took off further down into the tunnels,
looking forward to finding its next victim.
Sadly for SCP-682, it wouldn’t get to kill
the next set of victims.
A group of four Child Facelings - spooky,
faceless little girls who like to cut apart
their typically human victims with small objects
- were waiting a little further down the pipe.
However, when they felt SCP-682 approaching,
they almost sensed the power and cruelty of
the beast coming towards them.
Even being little monsters themselves, game
recognized game, and they knew that they needed
to get the hell out of there before the monster
arrived.
They climbed between the pipes on the tunnel
walls and skittered off into hiding places
deep in the dark.
Lucky for them, SCP-682 passed them and just
kept going.
What would be the point in wasting time on
these little morsels when there were apparently
so many other creatures to massacre down here?
Next, SCP-682 came across a truly pathetic
creature - Something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even interacting
with.
It was a creature known as a “Clump”,
a strange bundle of living limbs that will
move at great speeds and attack its usually
human targets.
It tried to do the same to SCP-682, manically
flailing its many twisted limbs.
682 killed it in a single stomp and moved
on, feeling its own psychological equivalent
of pity - but not that much of it.
Not long after mercy-killing the Clump, SCP-682
came face to face with a series of Hounds
- mutant humanoids who travel on all fours,
behaving in a wolf-like fashion.
This would, of course, be the stuff of nightmares
for your average human being, but would be
far more likely to put a being like the Hard
to Destroy Reptile to sleep with sheer boredom.
Humans acting like dogs?
That makes them even more worthless, the creature
thought, as it charged forwards and began
tearing the group of Hounds to shreds.
Minutes later, it was splitting off into an
adjoining tunnel, searching for more easy
entertainment.
But the deeper SCP-682 made its way into the
bowels of Level 2, the more it approached
a truly horrifying realization: The creatures
it was slaughtering here were even more boring
than the ones the SCP Foundation ceaseless
threw at it back on its native reality - or
at least, the reality where they’d contained
it.
Back in that world, it had faced giant, flaming
demi-gods with swords hotter than the sun.
It had faced some pale, shrieking monstrosity
that didn’t seem to die no matter what the
reptile threw at it.
There was the dark, gooey old man, the Immortal
Warrior from the Black Coffin, and even the
all-devouring bunny rabbit.
Here, it was killing the same wretched selection
of beasts again and again, a truly pitiful
offering.
Was this really the best this world had to
offer?
Incidentally, the next creatures it found
were literally known as the Wretches by the
human inhabitants of The Backrooms.
They were fleshy, zombie-like creatures that
682 figured the Sarkicists back home might
enjoy.
It couldn’t believe it was thinking fondly
of that old place while it carved the monsters
to ribbons with its claws.
It missed its old enemies, like Dr. Bright,
Dr. Clef, and even that irritating yellow
blob of snot.
The more it tried to take its mind off the
old world by killing its way through this
ant farm of endless tunnels, the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic.
For example, there were the Plague Goblins,
impish little creatures with masks like that
of a Plague Doctor.
682 found itself thinking almost fondly about
SCP-049, while it listlessly ate the tiny,
mischievous creatures like a depressed person
binging an extra-large pack of chips.
Even their tiny squeaks as they crunched between
the reptile’s terrible teeth gave it no
joy.
What a bleak turn of events this had all turned
out to be.
As it wandered through the infinite tunnels,
killing creatures and even humans as it found
them, SCP-682 made a quiet promise to itself:
Somehow, someway, it would make its way back
to the universe it’d so recently departed.
It would leave the Backrooms, no matter how
many levels, a quiet, burning husk, and return
to the world of fools and fiends it had taken
for granted all this time.
A visit to the Backrooms had taught the Hard
to Destroy Reptile an all-too-human lesson:
Sometimes, you don’t know what you have
until it’s gone.
Sure, the SCP Foundation may have tried to
kill it in a new, bizarre, and increasingly
sadistic way every single day, but that variety
was the spice of life.
It would return home someday, it knew that
much - But of course, a lot of creatures and
people would need to die before then.
But if that’s what it took, well, so be
it.
SCP-682 licked its dagger-like fangs, and
kept crawling…
If you want more of our take on the bizarre
liminal hell that is The Backrooms, go check
out our new channel, The Backrooms - Explained,
for more Backrooms content in our signature
style!
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“SCP-682 vs SCP Foundation - Hard To Destroy
Reptile Termination Attempts” for more of
everyone’s favorite ornery reptile!